a new hotel and casino coming to North
Las Vegas and it's the first of its kind
in our area co-host Loco Sports casino
and cantina opening Monday that didn't
stop Brian will from giving us an early
glance
if you're heading over to the Northwest
side of Las Vegas you'll soon notice a
gaming and entertainment destination
catering to the Latino Community it's an
incredibly underserved if not ignored
part of our community and uh I think
what we're doing here is it's really
special this new destination in North
Las Vegas has been a vision of Shores
for 15 years and is finally a reality
thanks to a partnership with a popular
texas-based Latino restaurant called
Ojos Locos meaning crazy eyes it's a
collaboration with Ojos Locos and their
first restaurant here in Las Vegas first
Ojos Locos Casino inside you'll find 200
state-of-the-art slot and gaming
machines 90 TV screens to choose from
and the Ojos Locos famous chicas the
venue servers and bartenders they're
also known for their cold drinks and
their food we're going to serve your
authentic Mexican food it is made from
scratch so we don't have anything Frozen
everything is fresh in addition to the
restaurant Casino you'll also find the
newly renovated 90 room Hotel Hefe
attached we're excited to see like Latin
Community come in and experience what we
call the host experience and all this
opens to the public on Monday reporting
in northwest Las Vegas Brian will 8 News
Now